SPEAKER: When creating
data product clusters
for using open source
big data tools,
such as Spark,
Hadoop, or Presto,
it is imperative that
they are configured
with well-defined
security settings
to prohibit unauthorized use
and access to the cluster.
Google Cloud contains
several options
for how to control the security
settings on your cluster.
So let's jump in and
learn more about this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In this video, we'll
be going over how
to secure your
Dataproc clusters using
a custom virtual
private cloud, or VPC.
A VPC is a managed networking
service for your Google Cloud
resources.
Resources within your VPC
are secured via isolation
from the public internet.
For more info on
virtual private cloud,
check out the video
link in the description.
We'll start by
setting up the cluster
to allow the cluster nodes
to connect to one another.
The cluster cannot distribute
workloads to its nodes without
this.
Additionally, we'll also allow
SSH access into the cluster.
SSH is important for
submitting workloads
with tools such as Spark Submit
and for making modifications
to long-running clusters.
We can do this by creating a
custom VPC with two firewall
rules, one that allows
the nodes of the cluster
to interact with each
other and another
that enables SSH access
into the Dataproc cluster.
These rules will provide
the Dataproc cluster
with basic security features.
Next, we'll create the
cluster with our custom VPC.
We'll then test the
functionality of the VPC
by submitting a Spark job to
the cluster using the Cloud SDK,
as well as show how to
SSH into the cluster.
We'll then delete the
individual firewall rules
and show how we protected
the cluster and the job
successfully.
Without the firewall
rules, we are locked out,
and the cluster is
effectively rendered unusable.
Yay.
You can jump ahead
to any of these steps
by visiting the chapters in
the YouTube description below.
Start by searching for VPC
network in the search bar,
and click on it.
Next, click Create VPC Network.
Provide a name for
the VPC network.
Next, we'll create a subnet
using the Custom Subnet
Creation mode.
Provide a name for
your new subnet.
Select a region.
In this case, we'll
pick US Central 1.
Provide an IP address.
We'll go with 10.0.0.0/9.
Leave the rest of the default
as is, and press Create.
This should take
about 20 seconds or so
to finish creating.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When it's finished
creating, click on it.
Click on Firewall Rules,
then click Add Firewall Rule.
We'll first create
a firewall rule
that will allow
nodes of the cluster
to communicate with each other.
Provide a name for the rule.
Make sure the name of
your network is selected.
Make sure the direction of
traffic is set to Ingress.
For target tags, provide
the name dataproc-network.
For source IP ranges,
input 10.0.0.0/9.
For protocols and ports,
check the box next to TCP,
and enter the ports 0-65535
to allow access on all ports.
Also, check the box next
to UDP and input All.
Press Create.
You'll see the new
firewall rule here.
Now, let's create our
second firewall rule
by again clicking
Add Firewall Rule.
This firewall rule will allow
SSH access to the cluster.
Provide a name for the rule.
Make sure the name of
your network is selected.
For target tags, again provide
the name dataproc-network.
For source IP ranges,
input 0.0.0.0/0.
For protocols and ports,
check the box next to TCP,
and enter the port 22, which
is the port used for SSH login.
Press Create.
We'll now create
our Dataproc cluster
configured with our VPC.
In the search bar, type in
Dataproc, and click on it.
Next, click Create Cluster.
Provide a name.
Select the same
region as your VPC.
Leave everything else
in this tab as is.
Next, select Customize Cluster.
Under Network Configuration, for
the primary network dropdown,
select your network, and for
the sub network dropdown,
select your subnet.
Under Network Tags, enter the
same tags you created earlier,
dataproc-network.
Everything else
will be left as is.
Go ahead and press Create.
We see our cluster is
provisioning, which will take
about 90 seconds to finish.
We'll skip the video ahead here.
Now that our cluster has
finished provisioning, let's
try submitting a job to it
using the Dataproc jobs API.
Click on the Cloud Shell button
to open up your Cloud Shell.
Now we'll copy this
command into the terminal
to submit an example
job to Spark.
In this case, will you Spark
Pi, which will approximately
compute the value of pi.
Great.
This worked.
We can see the success
message in the output.
Now, we'll go back to our VPC
and remove the firewall rule.
Again, search for VPC network.
Click on my-vpc-network-demo,
and then firewall rules.
Check the box next to
the cluster-coms rule,
then press Delete.
Now, we'll try submitting
the Spark job again
in our Cloud Shell.
After about 60
seconds, it will fail.
We'll again skip
the video ahead.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As you can see, the cluster
failed to execute the job,
as it wasn't able to communicate
with the other nodes.
This means having the
rule there worked.
Go back to the Dataproc
page by typing Dataproc
into the search bar.
Click on the cluster, then
click the VM Instances tab.
Next to the master
node, press SSH.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're now SSH'ed
into the cluster.
Let's see if we're moving the
firewall rule for SSH prevents
us from doing this again.
Close this SSH window, and now
let's search for VPC network
again.
Click on my-vpc-network-demo,
and then firewall rules.
Check the box next to
the allow-ssh rule,
then press Delete.
Go back to the Dataproc
page by typing Dataproc
into the search bar.
From the Clusters page,
click on the cluster.
Click on the VM Instances tab.
Next to the master
node, click SSH.
This process should hang
for about a minute or so
before unsuccessfully
connecting.
We'll skip the video again here.
This means the allow-ssh
firewall rule worked, as well.
In this video, we
created a VPC network
with two firewall rules
in place to limit access.
We then created a Dataproc
cluster configured with the VPC
network to secure
it via isolation
from the public internet.
We then tested the
functionality of the cluster
and showed this
functionality disappear as we
removed the firewall rules.
You can read more about
network configuration
for your Dataproc cluster
in the Google Cloud Docs.
Please go to this link
for more information.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]